devastating flooding has swept away
homes in parts of Oklahoma flood alerts
are up across half the state this
morning
Mireya Villarreal is in Weber's Falls
Oklahoma where the whole town was forced
to evacuate may a good morning good
morning last night people in Weber's
Falls were told to get out immediately
when two barges broke free and started
floating down the Arkansas River with no
one on board they were headed straight
for the dam that you see right below me
now the fear is that these barges could
breach the dam holding the flooded river
back from a town of about 600 people
officials lost sight of them briefly
overnight but found them stuck on a rock
several miles from the dam they are
working right now to secure them and
warn that if they get loose again
a breach would cause catastrophic flash
flooding the Arkansas River is already
approaching a historic high and take a
look at this
speaking of historic this world war two
submarine was sitting on dry land four
days ago
200 miles west of where we're standing
rising flood waters left some homes
clinging to the edge of the Cimarron
River in Oklahoma while other homes were
washed away completely in Missouri
torrential rain could top levees along
the Missouri River threatening to
submerge homes highways and farmland now
in the rest of the region a hundred and
forty five flood gauges have actually
shown that they are at a critical State
this is a big problem for the river and
people downstream but right now everyone
in this region is hoping the next few
days the rain will subside giving them a
chance to finally recover Gale sure hope
mother nature's listening they need a
break there Thank You Maria